i've not been on new york because you're
a boss babe you're not just using your
sexuality to
what's a boss babe well like a working
woman a woman who's like making you know
her own money um
never heard that
like i've heard it but i think boss babe
has really negative connotations i agree
boss babe is like i'm a boss [ __ ] i
don't need no man like [ __ ] men like
that's not me i agree i mean i agree
with you however making your own money
and making carving your own niche in
this world is you
but i just think that's human survival
you think so who else is going to pay my
bills well according to a lot of women
out there a man
which one
well you got to find i mean i'm on it
but i got to eat i got to eat in between
i got to eat in between i got to have
somewhere to live do i live on the
streets and do i would get a sugar daddy
no i don't want that yeah well a lot of
women do i know her own money so she can
get to the great places where the men
are yeah let's talk about this let's
talk about this i like gideon kind of
being a great uh segway over there the
leia hill pancho